the smell of your house alone when
you're baking cookies is a reason to
love chocolate chip cookies
i'm jen malouf i'm the owner and baker
of stuffed cookies stuffed is an online
cookie company all of our cookies are
brown butter based and stuffed with a
different filling in the center
so when you're making brown butter
you're looking for that medium brown
color but you can really let it go as
dark as you want i prefer to have it be
a little bit burnt which may seem scary
but it doesn't do anything except add
more flavor and it's just delicious
after your brown butter has chilled for
a little bit you could start creating
your cookie dough i use the creaming
method as we all should when making
cookies so you're going to want to cream
your butter and sugars until they have a
very creamy cloud-like texture this
aerates the butter and sugar which makes
the cookie dough a little bit lighter
since we're adding stuffing and mix-ins
we want to make sure our base isn't too
dense
[Music]
i like to gradually sift in my dry
ingredients to make sure they're really
well incorporated and there aren't any
lumps
[Music]
scraping the edges of the bowl is
essential when making the dough it will
ensure that all the ingredients are
consistent throughout and will give you
the best cookie possible
[Music]
one kind of chocolate chip is fine but i
like to add two sizes for a little
variation and the mini ones are just so
cute
in order to properly stuff your cookies
you're going to need to chill the dough
for about two hours in the fridge if you
don't you'll have a mess on your hands
go ahead and grab an ice cream scoop and
scoop out your cookie
flatten it out to about a quarter inch
thickness that way the stuffing won't
ooze out and then fill it with the
stuffing of your choice like cookie
butter is one of my favorites but
caramel is great because that just oozes
out of the center and it's so good
i've been baking for as long as i can
remember
my mom used to let me pour the dry
ingredients over the wet and it's
moments like that that have helped for
me into the person i am today
back when i was in culinary school i
used to bake stuffed cookies for my
whole family as christmas presents
because i was a college student i
started off with pretty basic flavors
and i gradually started adding in
crazier ingredients and they looked at
me like i was crazy but after they tried
them they were all obsessed
i got pretty amazing feedback from my
family and it encouraged me to start my
own business
[Music]
i like to add the toppings on top of the
cookie because i mean you put forth all
this hard work when baking a cookie and
you mix everything in the dough and no
one can see it we eat with our eyes so
why not put everything on top my cookies
are a reflection of myself and i think
that's what makes them so unique
it's crazy to think that someone random
across the states can be sitting on
their couch right now enjoying one of my
cookies that i hand made for them i
don't know about you but i think that's
awesome
i grew up eating chocolate chip cookies
everyone grew up eating chocolate chip
cookies it's just a fundamental part of
who we are so every time you take a bite
it just takes you back to your childhood
and that's my goal
our cookies are completely customizable
of course we have preset flavors that
you can choose from we also give you the
option to create your own cookies from
scratch you start off with selecting
your cookie dough stuffing and mixins
my favorite cookie that we make is the
recess cookie it's the perfect
combination of sweet and salty showcases
all of our favorite recessed thyme
snacks from when we're younger has
pretzels potato chips chocolate chips
peanut butter stuffing and a light
sprinkle of sea salt on top if sweet and
salty is your thing then trust me this
is your cookie
in my oven i like to bake my cookies for
11 minutes and 33 seconds but everyone's
oven is different so check on them at 11
minutes but they can go up to 14. you're
looking for them to be lightly golden
fully spread out and you'll have
yourself a beautiful cookie
biting into a warm chocolate chip cookie
fresh out of the oven provides you with
one of the top 10 best feelings in the
world and with my stuffed cookies
there's that extra element in the center
that just takes it to the next level
[Music]
you